okay um well done you guys have held on
i've shown you four methods have you
counted one a one b one c and then i
just showed you a secondary method with
this inscribed triangle here's my final
one in some ways it's the worst solution
um because it's the longest and most
awkward but it's actually it's it's
important to know that if you don't like
any of this other reasoning and that
kind of thing um there is a re there is
a way to bash your way through
algebraically it's just terrible but i
wanted to show it to you for
completeness because some people really
like the algebraic solution okay
if you want to handle this by algebra
and not touch a single um
a single thread of like geometric proof
and like like maybe you didn't like that
you're like i didn't know what the
centroid was or how you find it um this
is the way to do it but as you're gonna
see it's horribly inefficient geometric
reasoning whilst it can be difficult to
come up with it actually saves you time
okay they're kind of every property is
like a shortcut that you can use through
the proof okay
so
hold on to your hats let's just uh bash
this out mercilessly are you ready let's
let z equal x plus i y so therefore i
can say well i'm just going to
substitute that into the original
equation they provided us right there
was arg of z minus 2 root 3
arg of z minus 2i and when you take the
difference that's equal to pi on 3. i've
just written this on the left hand side
because i'm not going to do any
manipulation to it everything's going to
be changing over here okay now think
back when you um when you multiply
complex numbers together you um
multiply the moduli and you add the
arguments right which means when you
divide complex numbers you subtract
arguments and that's what you've got
here do you see you you've got one
argument and another you're subtracting
right so therefore if when you divide
complex numbers you subtract arguments
um the converse is also true when you
subtract arguments what you're really
doing is dividing complex numbers
this is one complex number and this is
another one so therefore what i'm going
to do is take these two arguments and
combine them into one
i'm going to combine them into an
argument where
i'm dividing uh this one here you can
see i've just collected the real terms
over here and x minus two root three um
and then you've got the i y hang it over
there on the right
and then in this
complex number i've just collected those
imaginary terms and then just factorized
out the i okay now as we've seen before
you look at this and you think yuck
mainly it's yuck because the denominator
is complex right so i need to realize
the denominator here but i'm really
sorry well not that sorry this is why it
wasn't one of the first four methods i
showed you when you realize the
denominator of this it's going to be
terrible because see what you've got to
do right you've got to multiply by the
complex conjugate of this denominator
which is x minus
i
y minus two which is gonna become a
dog's breakfast when you have a look at
the top so i'm just warning you in
advance that this is gonna become messy
okay
this is what you get when you're
multiplying by x minus i y on two this
is how it all pans out you can see i've
just paired up my x terms and my um
and my
i y minus two terms i've shaded them
blue and green just so you can follow
along a little more easily watch out
there's actually a few minus signs in
there that i've cancelled just to make
it briefer than i mean it doesn't look
brief at all but it's as brief as i can
get it
when you expand all of this out because
what i need to do is
isolate the real components and the
imaginary components it looks
even worse because you have to expand
this
pair of binomials in here but what it
does allow you to do is successfully
factorize i out and so there's a going
to be a real component here
and an imaginary component here and
they're going to be things that i can
separate out to then sort of crunch
through my algebra okay so that's what
i've done right here
here is the imaginary component here's
the sorry the real component here's the
imaginary component after you can see
the the xy terms here and here they're
just going to cancel with each other
which is nice
so once you've got that you say mr wu
what do i do
and i said that you didn't have to use
any geometric reasoning before but i
told a sort of brief lie
you can kind of define this
geometrically but it's easier to for me
to show to you what's going on here if i
reason it geometrically um if you think
about a complex plane right and you
place some arbitrary a plus ib
onto here right where is the argument of
a plus i b and the answer is it sits in
this right angle triangle here right
here's the argument uh here
and so you can see if i've got a plus i
b then i've got this as a and this is b
so therefore i've got this tan
relationship here right i can say tan of
theta tan of that argument is going to
be
opposite on adjacent which is b on a in
this case right
in this particular example i don't have
a nice neat a plus ib this monstrosity
here in purple is a
and this here in orange is b they're my
real and my imaginary components so what
i'm going to do from this line to the
next line is i'm going to take advantage
of tan this relationship over here oops
it is it didn't mean to delete it this
relationship over here i'm going to take
tan of both sides and just be careful i
can do this because i've got um i've got
everything in the first quadrant so
things are going to be positive and all
that kind of thing okay so on the left
hand side tan of pi on three is equal to
root three we've seen this before and on
the right hand side this is the b on a
that i was talking about there's b
and there's a so just so you know where
that's coming from you can see this um
coming or this coming down to the
numerator okay
uh when i look at this i think
gross but i can work with it right for
starters there's so many surge flying
around um the thing that i think is
probably most easiest is to get rid of
as many root threes as possible you
can't get rid of all of them but you can
get rid of some of them so i'm gonna
divide through by root three and these
terms which had root threes in them
before
they weren't
this one which didn't have one before it
will but that's still going to be okay
for me i'll i'll get rid of it shortly
so i've divided through by root 3 that
gives me a 1 on the left hand side
you can see what i was talking about on
the numerator here and now i'm ready to
cross multiply um you can see i can
multiply that denominator over to the
left hand side and mercifully because
it's equal to one i don't have to do any
like you know um complicated expanding
so you can see over here on the left
hand side that is the denominator you
saw before but i did do a couple of
things in the background right
i rationalized this um
this denominator here so it's 2 root 3
on 3 and while i was at it i knew that
this x term and this x term we're going
to have to collect eventually so you can
see i also rationalized this one this
came from the 2 root 3x term on the
denominator okay so these guys are going
to collect in a second
you can also see i will have these y
terms
to collect
and once you put them together you're
going to subtract 2y from both sides you
should land here right
so what i've got here is all of the y
squareds the two y's and that 4 fits
nicely i don't have to complete the
square on this because this is a square
but what you get over here because i'm
heading towards a circle right this is
going to need me to add something to
both sides to complete the square
and you can see here i halve and square
right this coefficient here so you have
it which gives you that you square it
which gives you that right hand side
which is the radius okay
so from there you can read off like the
center and radius from the equation of
that whole circle
what i did was
just going all the way back to the start
this this equation here defined the
entire
subset of the complex plane we were on
so that's why when i got all the way
through my horrendous algebra i got the
entire circle you do have to restrict it
to say it's the major arc but that's not
something that the question asks us to
do once you have the equation there you
just read off the radius and the center
so
how is your brain feeling has it
absolutely turned to mush
i do know there are other methods in
fact i'm going to really quickly
zhao is not here in the room anymore but
i'm going to really quickly show you
the reasoning he showed me i think let
me use this diagram because it's
actually the scale so that can be
helpful
um and i see should be put another one
in there um let me see another
oh okay yeah i see so yes you are using
um uh you know modulus notation there
for z minus two i and then saying okay i
can solve them to get the because you've
got equal distances you've got radii
that's fantastic let me show you jia
solution because it was quite nice as
well if you put in
these radii back here
we already know that this angle is pion3
from part one we already reasoned
through why this is two pi on 3 here
because of the angle at the center being
twice the angle at the circumference so
just store in your head that it's 2 pi
on 3 because these are both radii here
i'm going to delete this 2 pi and 3 just
so that i can draw a new construction so
if i sort of bisect this two pi on three
in here okay what that creates is a pi
on three on this side and a pi on three
on this side
and what you can reason here is because
you've got this radius here this radius
here and the pi on threes over here um
you can further reason that you're
actually going to create two congruent
triangles here right by dividing this uh
a b length into two we already know it's
equal to
four so when you divide it up into half
you get two on this side and two on this
side
by showing that they're congruent
therefore these two angles on a straight
line have to add up to pi so therefore
one of them is going to be pi 2 and the
other one is going to be pi on 2 and
from here knowing that this is pi on 3
you've got a little right angle triangle
in here that you can just use right
angle triangle trig what do we got here
so sine of pi on 3 will be 2 on r
sine of pi on 3 will be 2 on r so
therefore just rearranging i get r is
equal to 2 divided by sine pi on 3 which
is root 3 on 2 which is the same thing
we saw before this is for
uh root three on three once you
rationalize so you've got the radius and
then you argue from there from two i
horizontally across that gives you your
center so you can see there's just there
you go there's a sixth solution kind of
i think that's like solution 1d or
something so
what's my point here as we finish up and
thank you for your patience
the reason why i showed you all these
different methods is because i need you
to exercise in your mind the ability to
reason from many different angles part
of the pun right that's what's going to
help you like you don't need all of
these solutions in the exam but one of
them will be the one that clicks in your
mind most easily i particularly like
that we used let's have a look at method
two sorry
um
no not method two it's method one c this
one here right i think in many ways is
very different but it uses a lot of the
knowledge that you got before and it's
very unlike the other solutions because
you don't employ very much geometric
reasoning explicitly the complex numbers
and the arithmetic there kind of do the
work for you and that's one of the
attractions of complex numbers